hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry fear ok I'm back at the
subway finally so what do I need to do
about that get from here I'd have to put
a fuse in there what wasn't there
another way into the subway wasn't there
I mean I had I come out of the subway at
some point so how do I get back and I
don't want to in said I needed both
views so I don't want to put one in
there if I need to inside it dumped me
out after all those uses Oh
I've totally forgotten
mmm she's a mystery whatever you know
I'm here I might as well try it you know
if it's wrong I'll come back round and
get the few over now it's the only lead
I got so I might as well just try what
what what what what come on okay
balderdash
I gotta go the other way and try to get
into the subway the way I came out which
I can't remember call more backtracking
love it love it it's my favorite thing
in the world
sorry guys sorry for being so lost but
as you can see it's not entirely my
fault entirely a little bit my fault
50-50 my fault oh no no come on
game game I swear game you don't want me
to finish you my game crashed so I'll be
back in a second hello everybody and
welcome back we are still lost I can't
believe the game crashed on me again
okay um I got both fuses I don't know
where to go
I'm completely lost I am just the only
way I can take to go back now is if I go
see if I go and where the park was with
a big guys and then go down that hallway
where I thought it was a dead end but
maybe it wasn't maybe maybe I was wrong
maybe that's where I came in
some way I'm having trouble remembering
exactly one that subway happened but
maybe it's another way to go we'll be
happy when this year and be on my merry
way
I don't bigger punch it with my fist huh
you want fist watch the best I can do
crossbows
so that's where those monsters came out
this is where I popped up it must be
because how's the roof jumping thing
must have been farther back than I
thought it was because
the only place I could have come after
the subway was here right I had to come
here because it's where I got sir
housing come boss what I do with a bus
yeah yes oh okay yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes I could swing but why back in the
subway Oh what do I do
at least I'm
some ovett guys yeah that's where the
doctor look that guys
fine come on later
all right throw that way
they're either
no entry
I remember
oh wait a minute
- whew - fuses yeah I'm in it that's why
I never bothered to look at the frickin
wall here
[Music]
okay all right
also I'm sister okay bring on the
monsters bring on whatever I am the
great at home dogs so ready for that
which is perfectly normal sure there
would be escalators come on bud huh one
punch that's all it took Richard where'd
your body go you have a gun that I need
there we go
one punch just right now there
oh thank you thank you thank you oh man
oh man y-yes please send more of those
guys please don't I don't have much help
all right
yeah I don't have much health left no
after you yet I had to give up my
morphine good container because I was
out of space hey youtube
I'll see you boom headshot okay so I
won't be on my merry way
okay
and stairs to glory otherwise in the
moving sidewalk working I'm going down
today we it's like I'm going faster than
everyone walking okay I don't like that
wall I do not like that wall no entry
[Music]
okay this is the subway underneath
hello Morpheus fine I need that like all
was this yeah that scar is definitely
you can't have you can't well oh boy oh
boy another puzzle
someone wants to feed back back back
let's go find some feet drop them in oh
this is another double fuse I don't have
the inventory space or more fuses
ah maybe there's some way I can open
these gates because I know I know the
fuses are like right above these gates
alternate
ah don't know okay all right man
[Music]
I need two views and I need some guys
fleet
[Applause]
okay wall can be broken with moss v or
with my best huh yeah get okay so how do
I go about breaking said wall butt of my
gun
mom maybe I sprint into it funk no
butter the rifle wonk wonk don't know ok
that all right as a decorative looks
like a fire alarm or something oh damn
it
okay um broken what how tell me how
and I feel like I'm back Jackie oh well
maybe there was something down here that
I missed because it is kind of dark this
will be easy to pass things by still
gated here barred and gated just find a
sledgehammer maybe maybe that would do
it
watch why even have doors oh why have
doors
oh I thought it was finally making
progress my photos making progress this
is green
I tried to take the fuse there but
apparently I can't take them out there
must be something down here why would I
spend so much time trying to get down
here if I couldn't do anything about got
down here more than anything in the game
and I guess I hate more than that I hate
them giving me false hope I thought I
had made it I thought I finally that
maybe there's something on the other
walkway I thought I'd finally gotten
through and thought I finally stopped
being lost Here I am again lost I don't
know push up vending machine into it no
I don't know
well back here again maybe there was
something in this train that interest me
the Dorothy in there
maybe maybe please yes oh okay okay okay
okay
and that's like the least obvious thing
I've ever seen badly a hammer a
sledgehammer I called it
I needed a sledgehammer Paul thank you
sledgehammer gods
thank you serious Sam that's totally
channeling sue
oh oh you want thumb ah dad knock oh wow
where did you come from anyway you
crawled out in nothing
hey I see you I see you this is ham
atomic [ __ ]
it is hammer time oh you want some too
I'm gonna break that wall I'm gonna
break that wall guys you ready to be
fair that door was completely not
obvious the whole train was red or the
yellow and the door was yellow how was I
to know what what in clink was there
yeah come on
almost got here thing moving there we go
tumble down is that physics was that
physics in a half-life 1 mod I'm
impressed okay
oh yes forward I'll make this
so just a little bit longer just to like
it's an example whoa what okay I can get
through the door barely Stefano what the
[ __ ] that's funny whoa I see something
oh my goodness
Oh God
that is amazing that is awesome really
really awesome man
okay so actually I know let's keep going
carnage make you guys deal with the
lame-o was this
leave across here oh there's a safe one
right here okay all right yeah I will do
it for this episode finally making
progress a little bit slowly but surely
I'm pinching my way through thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
see you in the next part
bye bye